[Music]
here we go again
the ps+ games for April 2019 have been
announced and there's additional items
for fortnight and h1z1 this month to
remember there's no ps3 or Vita support
anymore those days are sadly gone PS +
titles are available from the first
Tuesday of the month so if you're ready
let's do this first up is the surge the
surge is a game in the style of Dark
Souls blood-borne and even Sakura to
some extent by that I mean it's hard
it's challenging to the extent it will
frustrate you in that lies the appeal of
the surge dare you fight on collecting
resources and xp order you back away and
save what you have dying takes away your
progress making fights anxiety-filled
and a single slip-up means huge amounts
of XP and progress can be lost
definitely a game for a certain type of
gamer the surge is a role-playing game
which is predominantly set in an excel
suit designed for battle the story is
science fiction based with a heavy focus
on technology and evolution going
hand-in-hand there's a really cool
mechanic worth mentioning which allows
us to target specific body parts of
enemies and dismember them in slow
motion unbelievably satisfying we then
use those body parts to upgrade our
exoskeleton the review scars range from
6.5 to 8 out of 10 but it's the
challenge which dictates how you feel
about the surge if you want a relaxing
switch your brain off game it's most
definitely not the surge but if you like
punishment and sci-fi pick it up what do
you think please share your feelings in
the comments below
Coenen exiles is our second title
officially released less than 12 months
ago exiles is a survival title set in
the world of Conan the Barbarian in
which we are rescued by Conan at the
start and then set loose on the world we
decide how our character looks and plays
with sliders for bigger boobs a 6-pack
of ABS a new quiff or even a bigger
package although I'm not sure if that
feature made it to the console version
Conan Exiles asks us to manage our
health deciding when to eat with gauges
depicting that and many other attributes
therefore we'll need to hunt we'll need
to forage and in this world everything
is
hostile so prepare to fight Coenen
exiles has been updated regularly with
the most noticeable addition the frozen
section of the map the weather can be
your demise
freezing to death or burning in the hot
Sun are pretty unpleasant ways to go
I'd rather die fighting of behemoths
singleplayer is all well and good but
Conan exiles becomes instantly more
playable in coop hunting and fighting
with your best friend by your side feeds
into the roleplay side of things
crafting and building play another huge
part in the game will you build a
massive fort to scare off others or a
Shack to wait out the Sam storm rolling
in the world is yours so survive your
way so will you try it let us know below
now I should be talking about ps3 games
but they don't exist anymore I'll get
over it one day but we do have a few
extras to look at PS plus players can
find a few items for free to download
fortnight players you have a new skin
and backup link to grab right now
h1z1 players you guys can get your hands
on a new bandit pack which contains an
ak-47 name card icon background and a
couple of master coins too so that's it
I'm still waiting for psvr to be added
to PS plus I won't hold my breath anyway
are you happy with April's offerings
let's chat about it below I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
as always and remember these games are
downloadable from the first Tuesday of
the month which is Tuesday the 2nd of
April right I'm done here I'll see you
next time